I did not hit her it's not true bullshit
I did not hit her I did not oh hi mark
hey Johnny what's up I have a problem
with Lisa she says that I hit her what
well did you know it's not true don't
even ask what's new with you well I'm
just sittin up here thinking you know I
got a question for you
yeah you think girls like a cheat like
guys do what makes you say that I don't
know I don't know I'm just thinking I
don't have to worry about that because
Lisa's loyal to me
yeah man you never know people are very
strange these days he's no girl she had
a dozen guys when we found out about it
beat her up so bad she ended up in a
hospital in Guerrero Street
what is thorry mark you're tearing me
apart Lisa welcome to my review for the
room one of my most requested reviews I
have ever had in my entire life this is
the first review in a new segment on my
channel now if you remember my Batman
and Robin review back in the day I
referred to Batman and Robin as a
hilarious 'ti it's a word that I made up
that describes a movie that is so bad
that it is good it is such an atrocity
that it's hilarious hilarious 'ti my
very first hilarious 'ti review is for
the room one of the best there ever was
the room is one of the most fascinating
movies I have ever seen in my life
because as you watch the film you are
consistently wondering how in the world
did this happened we do some research on
the movie you find that Tommy Wiseau the
star the director the writer this is the
guy that financed the entire movie as
well as well as having to replace his
entire production crew halfway through
the movie and get an entirely new one
because of the fact that everyone was
like dude what are you doing this is
horrible
what is the room about okay the room is
about a guy who's like a happy banker I
guess he's a banker yeah and he loves
his fiancee Lisa
except he never refers to her as his
fiancee it's always my future wife it's
like Tommy Wiseau didn't know what the
word fiance meant as he wrote the script
he was like uh what is
word for the future life uh we'll just
call it future life
however Tommy's future wife Lisa is a
total slut and she's having sex with
mark Jonny's best friend
all the while there's this guy named
Denny this creepy neighborhood kid likes
to come over and every once in a while
admits that he likes to watch them have
sex yeah he just walks in like hey guys
I'd like to watch you and they're like
uh uh that's funny Denny you know we
love you he's just like yeah I like to
watch you guys have sex it's a lot of
fun you guys are awesome you're my
favorite people the room is a movie that
is just consistently hilarious because
of how truly awful it is there are
screenings of this movie all over the
world all the time in Cleveland where I
live they show this movie the first
Saturday of every month at this one art
house theater they have you bring spoons
to throw at the screen every single time
a spoon related photography images in
the background because there are spoons
all over this movie why are the pictures
of spoons everywhere no one knows it's
just amazing also Tommy Wiseau clearly
couldn't think of any ways to construct
scenes in this movie because he has like
at least 50 minutes of this movie the
characters talking while they throw a
football around I would say there's at
least probably five full minutes of
people throwing footballs in this movie
it's impossible to review the room
without mentioning the 1990s cheesy sex
scenes even though this movie came out
in 2003 the sex scenes in this movie are
like Tommy Wiseau watched a bunch of
1984 porn and decided you know what I
want to do this we will do that I want
to have a whole bunch of sex with women
in the belly button because I cannot
actually have sex I don't know how and
so I think it goes in the belly button
right belly button sex worst sex scenes
ever filmed best sex scenes ever filmed
at the same time I did a parody of it in
the beginning of this video but perhaps
the most famous scene in this movie is
the rooftop conversation with Mark I did
not hit her it's not true it's bullshit
I did not hit her I did not oh hi mark
oh hey Johnny what's up I have a problem
with Lisa she said that I had her what
well did you know it's not true don't
even ask what's new with you well I'm
just sitting up here thinking you know
I'll log in that scene is so
thought-provoking and it says true
things about humanity it's friggin
terrible it's it's all terrible I also
can't go without mentioning the flower
shop scene in fact I'm just going to
show it to you because there's no way
that I can parody it correctly there's
no way that I can explain the amazement
you just have to watch the flower shop
scene because it's the flower shop scene
from the room please enjoy hi can I help
you yeah can I have a dozen red roses
please oh hi Johnny I didn't know was
you here you go
that's me how much is it it'll be $18 go
keep the change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye movies do not get
better than this really tell ya they do
movers get a lot better than this one of
the ways this movie actually became more
famous is half because of Adult Swim and
I witnessed it happen if you guys
remember years back Adult Swim did one
of their first April Fools pranks all
night on April Fool's they did nothing
but continuously play the room with the
edited sex scenes they had like weird
bars over all the sex scenes and I
remember I turned on the channel and I
was like just a chica chip chip chip
chip Gigi from then on the room just
kept developing this reputation for this
amazing comedy and if you want to have
an amazing time watching a horrible
movie the room is one of the best worst
movies ever made I fit a blue this world
so on these types of reviews I'm gonna
do a different type of grading scale
this movie for sure gets an F I mean
it's it's it's terrible however on the
hilarious 'ti scale this movie gets an
A+ because it is truly amazing in that
way in that way and only in that way if
you guys want to get together with your
friends and have a good laugh or just
with yourself and have a good laugh I'm
positive that the room will do that for
you I will try to do more of these
reviews as I see other films that I
think are so bad that they're amazing
and as always guys thanks very much for
watching and if you liked this let me
know and I'll do more and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nice bye bye hello doggy you're
my favorite customer haha well I'm just
sitting up here thinking you know
I'm just sitting up here thinking you
such as Cupid like stuff is all in my
face one thing this video told me is I
will never ever have long hair that's
for sure
disgusting what is story mark this thing
off me